what's up my fellow geeks zacky here
doning up in my new hardcore get up
because we're ready to rock out the new
playstation 5 update yeah that's my
jacket dude why you just gotta ruin
things for me man
every single time
[Music]
right so with the new update there's
going to be a few more features such as
an upgraded ui you've got 3d audio
technology for your tv speakers and the
most important thing here is the ability
to expand your internal storage by
adding an ssd
into the ps5 now for some of you geeks
out there you've probably explored the
option of having an external ssd or hard
drive to store your games like this
little boy over here this is the western
digital black p50 game drive ssd but the
only caveat here is that you will only
be able to transfer your ps4 titles and
ps4 save games
so it's good but not great and as gamers
we know we need more
more you see well
[Laughter]
behold
the n.2 ssd
specifically this
this is the western digital black sn850
nvme m.2 ssd
it's a pcie gen 4 ssd
and it has such a robust and hardly
designed
metal right there and super cool with
its heat sink
now this pcie gen 4 ssd is capable of
read speeds of up to 7000 megabytes per
second and write speeds of up to 5
300 megabytes per second that's blazing
fast
now of course if you're on a tight
budget there is a 500 gigabyte model and
it goes all the way up to 2 terabytes if
you're really a bottle of a gamer so
with that being said let's get to
installing the ssd
to get started all you need is two tools
if you will this is a flathead
screwdriver
and secondly
a little tiny phillips head screwdriver
now with that being said make sure that
your playstation 5 has
the new update installed already so
let's begin first thing you want to do
is to make sure
that your
ps5
is on the drive face up drive not the
logo drive
all right
we're going to take out the stand if you
have already or if you're not using the
stand well then just skip ahead to step
two and now
we need to pry off the face plate all
right so there's a little bit of some
jedi master trickery over here well
actually not that much but you want to
have your left hand on the corner
of the plate here and your right hand
you want to pull up and slide left
if that makes any sense so
just do it this way and slide so you can
see that
in the indentations here
it's supposed to slide leftwards and
then you have the plate out
yay
now this is the first time i'm seeing
the insides so to speak of the
playstation 5. you can see why there's a
huge fan for cooling
all right so what we're going to focus
here is this metal plate
so just take your
we phillips head and unscrew this and
you have no nails well simplest thing is
take screwdriver
now
there's a little screw over here with
a washer if you will and that's supposed
to level with the ssd later
don't lose this because once you lose
this you are
cool
and washer
two things
see this thing here
this is your nvme ssd slot
now before we install the ssd there's
one thing to note there's different
markings
on the
board itself
and you want to measure it so what you
want to do is just roughly gauge that
the ssd is
at the 80 mark
it could be possibly because there are
other ssds that might have different
lengths so do check that out first
now take the metal washer
and put it onto the 80 mark it's going
to help us out
later
tick
set ssd and there's a small one and a
big one
there should be a small one and a big
one and you know it's a line
you can kind of see it's halfway in
already and you hear a click
right now it's normal for the ssd to be
standing up a little bit
so we're gonna push this down
and screw it in with our small screw
so all you need to do
screw it down align with
a line with washer
you see this
not too tight but until
you know
it's snug
put back your face plate
put it back and again everything in
reverse so slide
down
forward
there we go here the snap
and
everything is snug
oh it's 10.
essentially you are done let's pull back
the stand if you need to and we're going
to test out this bad boy by transferring
some playstation 5 games
all right so now that we got the m.2 ssd
installed to the ps5 you'll be greeted
by this message telling you that it
needs to be formatted first so all we
need to do is to format the m.2 ssd
so fast 50 100 wow
that's fast all right
and the read speed follows 6550.984
megabytes per second
close enough
click ok
and and it tells you
that your m.2 ssd has been formatted and
to change where your games are installed
go to settings storage and installation
location
all right
and we can skip this all right so all we
need to go settings
storage
and then you can see the m.2 ssd storage
is there
and that's where we can go to our
install location for ps5 games and apps
we can
go to the m.2 ssd storage
i'm just gonna try out transferring this
224.9 gigabytes
of storage right there let's see how
long it takes to
let's move it
there you go
barely a song in
and
well took less than three minutes i hope
that's pretty quick i expected longer
and let's try
moving another game
which is ghost of sushima
and let's time this ash well
that was fast
okay
the read and write speed says it all man
so there you have it folks i mean you
can really tell that the ssd work
just as well as the internal storage on
the ps5
blazing blazing fast speeds and we're
gonna give you the actual timings
right here
yeah what
black
call of duty black ops in less than
three minutes go so sushima let's say
what one minute
that's all thanks to this dude there you
have it folks
the ps5 update
are you able to install an extra ssd you
can compatible ones of course with the
ps5
and
look if you want to get this for
yourselves do check out the link in the
description below for more details on
pricing whether it's the 500 gigabyte
model or a 2 terabyte model let us know
in the comments down below if you guys
enjoyed this video don't forget to give
us a like and hit that subscribe button
helps us out a lot and until then
see you on the next one adios
[Music]
you